[Musique]
pasteur Isabelle aumônier protestant de
la onzième PP et je suis aumônier depuis
20 ans et je suis la maman de trois
enfants les plus fantastiques que le
monde et jamais vu
je suis lemonie Moïse
de défense Paris Île-de-France pour le
culte israélite
yousra aumônier passionné d'histoire
je suis affectée sur la base aérienne de
Tours
puis donc le padre François-Marie
affecté depuis un an et demi à la 13e
demi brigade de Légion étrangère je suis
prêtre catholique j'aime bien tous les
sports extrêmes je suis addict à la moto
j'aime bien le parachutisme j'aime bien
les sports de combat j'aime bien la vie
en extérieur en tout cas est
passionnément le bon Dieu
[Musique]
aujourd'hui en France environ 200
aumôniers portent l'uniforme ces soldats
sans armes servent en vertu d'un contrat
et sont soumis à la discipline générale
des armées ils assurent le soutien
spirituel et moral des personnels et
interviennent dans le conseil aux
commandements mais qui sont ces hommes
et femmes de foi qui ont choisi de se
confronter aux zones de combat et quel
est leur quotidien en métropole
ils sont toujours respectés parfois
questionnés jamais un cours de bons mots
les aumôniers occupent une place
particulière dans les armées
figure atypiques dans un monde très
normé ils font depuis longtemps partie
du paysage militaire
au Moyen-Âge déjà lorsque le Seigneur
partait en guerre il était accompagné
par un chapelain qui accompagnait les
soldats lors de ces opérations lors de
ses expéditions guerrières et puis tout
au long de l'histoire de la France on
trouve des figures de prêtres des
figures de Chapelain accompagnant les
armées les choses commencent à se mettre
en place réellement à partir de Napoléon
III Napoléon III dans les années 1850
1860 fixe déjà un cadre un peu général
d'organisation de l'aumônerie c'est un
début c'est un début
d'institutionnalités étatique de cette
fonction à l'intérieur des armées qui
bientôt va trouver à travers les lois de
1874 les lois de 1880 aussi de juillet
1880 une véritable expression
institutionnelle quelques années plus
tard l'article 2 de la loi de séparation
de l'Église et de l'État de 1905 prévoit
ainsi la mise en place de monneries au
sein des établissements publics fermés
tels que les lycées collège école
hospice prison ou caserne pourquoi
est-ce que dans un régime moderne qui
s'est dissocié de la loi de Dieu on peut
dans un corps particulier celui de
l'armée fait appel aux homonies
je dirais pour pour deux raisons il y a
une raison qui est d'ordre juridique et
puis une raison qui est d'ordre
fonctionnel la raison d'ordre juridique
et celle-ci
nous sommes avec la modernité confrontée
non seulement la liberté de conscience
mais à la liberté de culte qui prolonge
la liberté de conscience il faut dans
tous les espaces fermés dans tous les
espaces clos et y compris d'ailleurs les
espaces relevant de l'État relevant de
l'administration public que cette
liberté puisse s'exercer puis il y a une
raison fonctionnelle c'est le fait que
les militaires sont confrontés à des
épreuves ultimes épreuves de la
souffrance l'épreuve de la mort
l'épreuve de la blessure il convient y
compris d'ailleurs la blessure
psychologique que une parole de
réconfort les accompagnent sur le chemin
de la guerre
[Musique]
il existe désormais 4 aumôneries
militaires correspondant au culte
catholique protestants israélite et
musulmans de cette manière les armées
veillent à ce qu’une stricte équité soit
appliquée afin que chacun puisse
pratiquer sa religion ou qu'il se trouve
cependant tout aumônier quel que soit
son culte d'appartenance et son statut
se doit d'être en premier lieu
l'aumônier de tous les militaires sont
exceptions
militaire a pour fonction selon les
textes d'être une aide au commandement
et un soutien pour les hommes un soutien
pour les hommes à soutien
spirituel moral humain et une aide au
commandement c'est-à-dire de pouvoir
retransmettre si besoin ou transmettre à
nos chefs à la hiérarchie le ressenti le
vécu le moral des hommes de la troupe
dans toutes les situations auxquelles
peut-être confrontée pour que l'émission
et que se passe sous le même possible
comme ces homologues le rabbin Moïse
détient le gras du Nil de monnaie
militaire une particularité qui est un
gage d'accessibilité
lorsque je parle à un soldat qui soit
caporal sergent ou tout simplement
engager volontaire j'ai le même grade
que lui mais lorsque je parle à un
capitaine un colonel ou un général on a
officiellement le même grade que lui
donc on lui peut lui parler des galets
c'est un grand avantage que nous armées
ce qui est pas le cas dans les armées
étrangères aux États-Unis ou en
Angleterre ou dans d'autres armées ou
l'aumôniers a véritablement agrade dans
la hiérarchie militaire notre non grade
permet d'être hors hiérarchie et permet
aussi que tout le monde puisse venir
exprimer quelque chose une joie une
peine
il vaut mieux venir parler à l'aumônier
effectivement que de venir casser la
gueule de son voisin c'est préférable et
effectivement certains le font
je sais pas si je me sens plus utile
mais en tout cas il y a une grande joie
en tout cas de voir repartir ces gens
souriant
très efficace capteur du moral des
troupes ils sont aussi un soutien pour
les familles de militaires
bonjour Fabrice
ce jour-là le Père François Marie
aumônier catholique de la 13ème
demi-brigades de Légion étrangère
passons-terrir de l'avancée d'une
commande un peu particulière
bien sûr donc un ami le rouge et le vert
par rapport à la tresse et là c'est la
croix de l'aumônier c'est ça avec les
feuilles
militaire catholique et après c'est le
même chose que ça en fait la même chose
que ça reproduit ici au centre et ce
tissu blanc en fait vous le voyez pas
peut-être
à la caméra mais c'est le l'aube c'est
donc l'aube que je vais revêtir le jour
de Noël pour célébrer la messe de Noël
le padre comme tout le monde l'appelle
est une figure incontournable du
régiment et surtout une épaule solide
plis pause
c'est vrai que on a besoin d'une écoute
pour dire voilà c'est ça pas de pour moi
oui spirituel et puis même si certaines
partages pas la même fois il y a quelque
chose au-delà des liens au-delà qui font
que on est on se sent uni et le fait
d'être reconnu en tant que épouse de
militaire comprise et
puis on a des moments de fou rire
pour nous c'est une présence humaine
et qui devait être là
le padre il est là pour tout le monde en
fait dans ma vocation en tout cas ça
permet aussi un équilibre de vie de
pouvoir rencontrer des familles de
pouvoir rencontrer des familles avec des
enfants de pouvoir enfin voilà voir
aussi autre chose que le monde militaire
du quotidien
et à quelques jours de Noël il est très
sollicité
je ne me lasse pas de vous remercier
remercier de venir chanter parce que on
va célébrer Noël ensemble peut-être que
parmi vous vous allez célébrer Noël pour
la première fois il y en a qui vont
fêter Noël pour la première fois
première fois première fois la légion
mais première fois de toute première
fois
toute première fois OK
donc c'est un vous allez voir vous allez
voir c'est un moment exceptionnel
[Musique]
est plus qu'une fête religieuse à la
Légion étrangère c'est un moment où
l'ensemble des légionnaires cadre et
homme de troupes se réunissent quel que
soit leur croyance une fête de famille à
laquelle tout le monde participe au long
terme autour de l'aumônier
et après avoir exercé ses cordes vocales
rien de mieux que le traditionnel
challenge sportif mode béret vert pour
consolider les liens
à la troisième compagnie et finiront le
challenge de développer couché la C1
passe à la sixième compagnie
[Musique]
une ambiance festive à laquelle le padre
se joue un sans se faire prier bien
évidemment
le soir même à 600 km de la dans une
atmosphère plus studieuse nous faisons
la connaissance de yousra en visite au
Britannie nationalement militaire de La
Flèche aumônier pour le Culte Musulman
elle suit un petit groupe d'élèves une
activité qui ne s'inscrit pas dans une
démarche prosélyte mais qui a pour but
d'écouter et d'échanger avec ceux qui en
font la demande et ce soir les jeunes
parlent de vivre ensemble
on sait qu'il y a des avis très
comment dire Xavier extérieur sur les
similaires parce que les la plupart des
élèves sont très fermés très très fermés
d'esprit mais moi je l'ai pas du tout
ressenti comme ça justement mais mais
mes copines qu'ils étaient dans ma
section qui s'était catholiques ou alors
à thé ou alors voilà qui c'était de tout
horizons elle elles ont elles sont
intéressées enfin elles sont intéressés
à moi je me suis intéressée à elle si on
a un bon feeling avec la personne qu'on
est amis on change pas trop à savoir de
quelle région à part si on change
vraiment à savoir des informations
intimes sur elle mais sinon c'est pas
c'est pas des choses qu'on se pose au
premier abord
cet ancienne officier enseignante
chercheuse prend beaucoup de plaisir à
dialogués avec ses lycéens des lycéens
très ouverts et pas surpris de voir une
femme homonie musulman en effet yousra
n'est pas imam en revanche elle est
diplômés en science islamiques et peut
répondre à de nombreuses questions
l'immeuble c'est un homme c'est sûr mais
moi quand j'allais à l'école coranique
quand j'étais petite et
toutes mes professeurs c'était des
femmes elles ont signé aux filles aux
garçons à tout le monde ça a jamais posé
aucun problème enfin aujourd'hui
en France il y a encore des petits
arriérés qui font que lui les hommes ont
des gros postes et des femmes sont tu
auras des pâquerettes mais c'est pas
vrai du tout mais quand elle est venue
elle nous explique son parcours bah
voilà c'est admirable il faut le dire et
après moi je suis un garçon c'est
d'autant plus rassurant ben que ce soit
justement une femme qui à qui on peut
faire confiance qui s'occupe de nous en
Islam
la femme a une un grand rôle dans la
transmission du savoir concrètement dans
mon métier tous les jours effectivement
ça surprend un petit peu parce qu'on a
des a priori des préjugés sur l'islam
qu'on ne connaît pas finalement et comme
je dis souvent en rigolant puis à la
télévision et puis il y a la réalité
le lendemain matin nous retrouvons
yousra sur la base aérienne 705 de Tours
où est installé son bureau un bureau
qu'elle occupe bien peu car son
périmètre d'intervention est très étendu
de Saumur au Mans en passant par Angers
difficile de souffler
malgré cette emploi du temps chargé
Lemonnier et c'est toujours de
participer à la vie des unités pour
toucher du doigt le travail de chacun
mais c'est intéressant pour vous
entraîner entre cadre ça vous permet de
faire des choses vous pouvez pas faire
avec les élèves par exemple
c'est surtout nécessaire
s'intéresser comprendre la réalité de
ces semblables fait quasiment partie de
l'ADN de yousra la création d'une
aumônerie musulmane en 2005 la plus
jeune des quatre aumôneries a donc été
pour elle l'occasion de réfléchir à une
autre forme d'engagement ça a été dans
mon dans le cadre de mon parcours très
naturel de passer de d'enseignante à
aumônier parce que alors l'enseignant
est au service des autres il est dans la
relation aux autres le la relation
humaine
et l'aumônier de dans toute sa splendeur
aussi
l'une des premières missions de yousra a
été d'inaugurée la salle de culte dédiée
aux musulmans sur la base un espace où
chacun est libre d'aller se recueillir
ou se confier
musulmane sur base avec des instants de
cohésion ça me rappelle un peu d'où je
viens ça me rappelle mes origines et ça
fait du bien de temps en temps c'est une
à deux fois par an parce qu'on fait pas
ça non plus tous les mois ou toutes les
semaines mais une à deux fois par an
c'est c'est très plaisant de pouvoir
discuter entre nous se retrouver manger
c'est sympa c'est des moments de voilà
se rappeler d'où on vient
en parallèle l'aumônier qui est aussi
une grande travailleuse s'est lancé un
défi ambitieux à la hauteur de sa
passion
n'hésite pas de pardon j'ai une fonction
de recherche dans dans le musulman nous
armées parce que je suis chargé de
mission histoire
cette mission Mémoire et Patrimoine de
l'aumônerie musulmane aux armées
constituent une tâche annexe un peu
particulière que que
j'affectionne puisque elle a pour but de
retracer le parcours des anciens
combattants musulmans de l'armée
française
nous la retrouverons d'ailleurs un peu
plus tard à Paris lors de l'inauguration
de son premier projet phare
départ c'était 0,5 02
j'essaye de vivre le quotidien avec eux
donc oui j'y passe de longues journées
voire de longues nuits aussi que ce soit
faire du sport avec eux que ce soit
aller sur le terrain avec eux que ce
soit mangé avec eux partir en bivouac
avec eux d'être là où ils sont sans pour
autant
chercher d'abord à leur parler du bon
Dieu je vais pas tirer tes munitions ça
va
juste regarder
ce qui me frappe toujours ce qui
m'interpelle c'est que je suis toujours
bien accueilli je suis toujours frappé
du regard du regard de ces personnes je
travaille en tout cas et je m'asstrains
aller regarder aussi dans les yeux parce
que je trouve que le regard dit beaucoup
et j'ai beaucoup de témoignages aussi y
compris de noms catholiques qui me
disent ah pas de règle quand on vous
voit on va mieux
même s'ils ont le statut de personnel
non combattant le terrain est loin de
faire peur aux homonymes
il suffit de regarder la pasteur
Isabelle pour son convaincre
sourire vissé aux lèvres Lemonnier
protestant achève une marge de 35 km qui
clôte la formation initiale de jeunes
engagés du troisième régiment du
matériel un défi qu'elle a relevé pour
l'exemple et sans se départir de sa
bonne humeur
votre
les moyens qui sont
mis à leur disposition la marche obérée
fait partie des moments les plus
significatifs pour toutes les
parachutistes et être là auprès de leur
dire moi aussi je vais ramasser comme
vous parce que parce que je crois que
c'est important d'être auprès de vous ça
me semble avoir du sens et puis aussi
leur donner un peu de courage
qu'aujourd'hui je pourrais être ta mère
moi je la fais la marche à la remonte me
dis pas que tu arriveras pas à la monter
oh ça leur met le sourire et ils y vont
aussi
malgré les courbatures Isabelle reprend
ses tournées matinales une vraie pasteur
de combat comme d'anciens camarades
aiment l’appeler
un café quelques mails rédigés à son
bureau au premier régiment du Train
parachutiste et elle repart comme yousra
Isabelle souvent les routes avec 14
régions à soutenir sa voiture est aussi
devenue sa seconde maison ce qui compte
c'est de voir les gens régulièrement
donc avoir un
flot continu de déplacement pour pour
être visible pour faire du lien
pour que le jour où il se passe quoi que
ce soit les gens sachent que je suis là
que j'appartiens au dispositif
[Musique]
si la pasteur arpente de nombreux
bureaux elle n'oublie pas celui des
chefs de corps
très bien pour faire remonter certaines
informations mais pas que
la poster c'est un peu un médecin de
l'âme et comme la première matière
première d'un régiment ça reste ça reste
l'homme forcément on a des intérêts
communs sur la santé de nos soldats et
puis un jour on sait très bien que on
peut être confronté à des situations
dramatiques et que l'appui de l'aumônier
de la pasteur sera aussi nécessaire pour
l'intéresser que pour le chef de corps
que je suis parce que on a toujours un
petit peu en ligne de mire la solitude
de commandement
vous aussi toujours c'est important de
pouvoir passer un peu partout en ayant
de la confiance
en sachant qu'il y a pas de défiance sur
qu'est-ce qu'elle va dire qu'est-ce
qu'elle va entendre comment elle va
redire les choses etc quand je passe au
régiment je sais que le chef de corps
c'est que je suis dans les murs pas
forcément effectivement dans son bureau
mais en tout cas auprès des jeunes et
que ce que je sais ce que j'entends je
le traite à mon niveau quand je peux
être un appui au commandement sans être
un souci une devise qu'elle a fait
sienne et qui fait d'elle une médiatrice
de choix
[Musique]
l'aumonie israélite Moïse se définit
aussi comme un facilitateur nous le
rejoignons cette fois en plein cœur de
Paris à l'Institution nationale des
Invalides un établissement de pointe
spécialisé dans la prise en charge des
blessés de guerre d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui ainsi que des victimes du
terrorisme
il est accompagné de Jacqueline qui est
réserviste citoyenne auprès de
l'aumônerie israélite bonjour et avec
cette pétillante sexuelle génère
surnommée par les pensionnaires la dame
au chapeau l'accueil est toujours
chaleureux pour les hôpitaux c'est
quelque chose de particulier et les
Invalides encore plus particuliers parce
qu'effectivement il y a des parcours de
vie d'existence extraordinaire pour les
anciens résistants anciens combats
ancien déporté ou un militaire
quel que soit leur statut leur visite
régulière permettent de tisser des liens
forts avec les patients le personnel
soignant ou les autres bénévoles
là aussi chacun est toujours considéré
avec bienveillance peu importe sa
religion
c'est le fait d'être là qui permet
justement d'aider ou qui permet de
soulager le fait de parler ou seulement
d'écouter parfois c'est un geste le fait
de tendre la main qui va être justement
le le travail de l'aumônier et parfois
effectivement humainement c'est
difficile parce que on voit des blessés
parce que
quel ou tel militaire vous raconte les
problèmes qui peut avoir ou le fait que
il a été il a été confronté à la mort et
là effectivement donc là aussi on n'est
pas moins un
et donc pas insensible à la souffrance
des autres un poids que les aumôniers
acceptent aussi de porter
dans un autre arrondissement tandis que
la nuit tombe sur la capitale le cœur de
youssra bat un peu plus vite qu'à la
coutumi
l'exposition itinérante soldat de France
l'engagement des soldats musulmans de
1802 à 1962 pour laquelle elle a
sacrifié quelques heures de sommeil est
inauguré à la Grande Mosquée de Paris en
présence de nombreuses autorités
un amour grâce à ces tranches de vie
c'est la diversité de nos armées
c'est la notion d'engagement et ce sont
nos racines communes qui sont mises en
valeur
je vous remercie vraiment que tous ces
symboles forces soient là dans cette
exposition
l'occasion aussi pour la secrétaire
d'État de rappeler quelques fondamentaux
au sein de l'armée française la
neutralité comme la laïcité sont des
principes naturels car c'est une
garantie de notre vivre ensemble et
surtout de notre bien vivre ensemble il
peut être patriotique ce soir les
barrières disparaissent les aumôniers
des différents cultes se mélangent
symboles d'une fraternité d'armes bien
réelle yousra a réussi son pari susciter
l'intérêt sur une page d'histoire encore
trop méconnue
peuvent porter cette voie puisque les
aumôniers sont avant tout porteurs
d'espérance et je pense qu'à travers ce
genre de sujets ce genre de
développement nous pouvons porter
l'espérance d'une jeunesse française
porter l'espérance de l'engagement
porter l'espérance
d'un avenir
plus radieux pour pour ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas le présent je pense que c'est
très important que l'aumônerie puisse
porter ce genre d'espérance
dans quelques semaines elle partira à
présenter le fruit de son travail dans
plusieurs lycées puis préparera son
départ pour sa première opération
extérieure
en zone de combat la présence des
homonies est particulièrement appréciée
indispensable même diront certains
l'éloignement avec les proches la dureté
des missions les doutes autant de sujets
que les militaires ont souvent besoin
d'évoquer avec les hommes et femmes de
foi
ils sont souvent présents dans ces
moments où la vie des soldats
la pasteur Isabelle ne pourra jamais
oublier ce 18 août 2008 en Afghanistan
cette embuscade à housebine ou 10
militaires ont perdu la vie le médecin
responsable de l'antenne médicale m'a
dit mais Isa moi je m'occupe des corps
toi tu vas t'occuper de l'âme de ceux
qui sont qui sont opérés ou examinés
après je prends les grands blessés tout
de suite les autres ils étaient tous
donc mis en attente et j'ai passé ma
nuit avec eux à écouter à entendre
à les écouter dire redire ce qui venait
de vivre
il venait de vivre l'enfer l'horreur ils
avaient besoin d'en parler mais ils
avaient besoin aussi qu'il y a une
oreille qui soit là prête à écouter
alors c'est sûr il y avait le bureau des
opérations qui traitait les choses
terriblement militaires il y avait des
médecins qui traitaient les corps
blessés et qui triaient l'urgence etc
mais ceux qui étaient en seconde zone
qui était les moins impactés
physiquement il fallait aussi être là et
c'était la place de l'homonie d'être là
j'ai proposé à tous de prier pour eux
pas un infuser
difficile d'évoquer ses souvenirs sans
émotion malgré les risques isabelle n'a
jamais hésité à monter en première ligne
pour être aux côtés des soldats
mais le jour où ça commence à tomber de
partout
vous vous dites
ça va peut-être mettre maintenant
vous dites si c'est maintenant pourvu
que ça soit vite
puis c'était pas si c'était pas mon
heure
et c'est étrange aussi on se dit presque
pourquoi moi je suis encore en vie
et ça c'est bizarre
et puis vous oubliez parce qu'il y a les
autres qui sont là et puis parce que
vous êtes le pasteur du théâtre donc on
prend la musette et c'est reparti
aujourd'hui du sel au Levant près de 12
aumôniers des différents cultes sont
déployés en permanence sur les théâtres
d'opération
au total 200 homonymes renforcés
périodiquement par des réservistes
officiers dans les armées
on trouvait leur place présent sans être
pesant ces hommes et femmes accompagnent
au quotidien les soldats sans jamais les
juger dans le pire comme dans le
meilleur